[Musique]
messieurs
alors on est prêt 1 2 3 en fait partie
[Musique]
nous allons définir partie assez fort en
fête avec mes collaborateurs et on a
imaginé en fait faire un grand volume
unitaire avec un plafond unique en bois
départ voix très absorbante parce que le
confort est rustique est essentiel la
peur un restaurant bien évidemment tout
c'est un moment de calme et tranquillité
avec le des matériaux aussi absorbant au
sol
donc
des matériaux souples et résistantes
donc vous voyez ce volume avec des
contrastes
dans lequel la lumière entre partout des
espaces nous avons fait il modifié à ces
normes deux choses créer des mezzanines
pour que le futur restaurant puisse
bénéficier partout des spas s'éclairer
avec une vue vous voyez une ambiance
assez cosy donc avec des matériaux qui
valorise l'espace donc un sol qu'on a
décidé assez sombre des meubles à c'est
assez clair des murs est très clair pour
apporter la lumière est partout vous
voyez ces parois perforé qui sont
destinés à apporter une qualité
acoustique est très importante pour le
bâtiment
c'est un restaurant de 800 couverts il
ya 500 m² de cuisine il ya mille 6000 m²
deux salles à manger
le bâtiment est plus destiné aux
entreprises qui sont déjà sur le site au
cea de saclay qui est donc comme suit un
gîte ami qui occupent 40 espace ici où
différents espaces de recherche aussi
qu'ils seront plus ou moins social et la
cité donc une clientèle plutôt là je
dirais grenade un match moyen et non pas
ce mois des étudiants
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]